okay so let's get right back into it
because it's been a very busy a news
weekend
Devon Nunez Republican congressman from
California as I told you earlier has now
been implicated in the Ukraine Fiasco
Republican congressman Devin Nunez the
same guy who was running to the White
House to talk to Trump while he was
running the House Intelligence Committee
investigation of Donald Trump the same
guy who was asking the questions during
the last two weeks of Trump impeachment
inquiry hearings is now accused of
meeting with Ukrainian officials and
being one of those people looking for
dirt on Joe Biden and we have travel
records that corroborate at least the
timing of these allegations and Devin
Nunez appeared on Fox Business channel
yesterday and he was interviewed by
Maria Bartiromo now understand Maria
Bartiromo used to be sort of inoffensive
financial journalist on CNBC when I was
growing up I was a teenager I was
starting to get into understanding
stocks and markets and so on and so
forth and she has become one of the
biggest sycophantic Trump brown-nosing
journalists in the ecosystem over the
last few years of the Trump era she
interviewed Devin Nunez and asked him
straight up Devin is this true did you
go to Vienna like Rudy Giuliani's
henchmen left Parnas alleges and meet
with Viktor Shokan and Devin Nunez not
only doesn't answer he doesn't answer in
the most absurd way possible which to us
is completely transparent as a lie but
unfortunately because he invokes the
idea of fake news CNN this probably will
be pleasurable to many Trumpets who have
been conditioned by the meme of fake
news he says you know I can't talk about
that because the allegations that I did
this are criminal implicating CNN take a
look at this video where are you in
Vienna with Shokan yeah so look Maria I
really want to answer all of these
questions and I promise you absolutely
will come back on the show and answer
these questions but because there is
criminal activity here we're working
with the appropriate law enforcement
agencies we're gonna file all this
everyone's going to know that
Ruth everybody's gonna know all the
facts but I think you can understand
that I can't compete by trying to trying
to debate this out with the public media
when 90% of the media are totally
corrupt and because this is criminal in
nature and because it's so bad it's so
slanderous we've got all the facts on
our side and we're gonna file in federal
court because I'm not going to sit here
and try to compete against the media
that I have no chance of winning with I
will win in court and they'll have a
chance to cooperate and they'll have to
to show how they work with somebody
who's been indicted which is you know
likely conspiring to obstruct justice so
so I want to just be clear before I move
on I'm gonna get your take on the
impeachment hearings but but just to be
clear you're saying you're suing CNN
you're gonna sue Daily Beast you you I
know you you've sued Twitter in the past
do you think this is going somewhere
you're telling me that CNN committed
criminal activity
well it's it's very likely all you need
to know is that you didn't hear a no you
didn't hear Deven unis ate now I wasn't
in Vienna meeting with Viktor Shokan
that was nowhere in there that's what
you call yes he was there he will say it
was for some other reason eventually
when it can no longer be denied that he
was there he's pretending that he simply
can't compete with the media narrative
that is against him as he claims to be
the reality is it's obviously true it
already has been corroborated at least
circumstantially by the financial
records of his travel to Europe at the
time in question simply say you weren't
there if you weren't there the idea that
CNN is criminal here is of course it's a
red herring it's a complete miss
direction but it's sadly a misdirection
that will probably be effective on a lot
of Trumpets who have been swayed by the
supposed CNN his fake news narrative
Devon Nunez got caught and now all he
can do is pretend he can't talk about it
because he's suing this person and he's
suing that organization and this could
all end up real
going backwards for Devin Nunez because
as I've already told you there are
congressional travel records that
corroborate this he appears to have done
this on your dollars on taxpayer dollars
there are recordings of Trump and
Giuliani where for all we know this was
discussed which Lev Parnas has provided
to the House Intelligence Committee
where we are headed is that Adam Smith
not Adam shift shift runs the House
Intelligence Committee Smith runs the
House Armed Services Committee it's a
different congressman Adam Smith says
that Nunez probably has another ethics
probe coming against him he was already
the subject of an ethics probe in 2017
were you in Vienna with Victor Shokan I
want to answer these questions and
someday I will come back and do it after
endless frivolous lawsuits work their
way through the system and you've long
forgotten about my involvement in this
that is effectively what he is saying
and and by the way Maria Bartiromo the
interviewer again a total trump
brown-noser she pretends that this
answer makes sense it seems like she's
actually going to ask a question to try
to just get a straight factual statement
declaration from Devon Nunez bottom line
were you in Vienna with Victor Shokan
and then Devon Nunez launches into this
I'm the victim I'm a martyr everybody's
after me it's all illegal it's all
criminal what's been done to me by even
suggesting this and Maria Bartiromo
plays a long thing right right he says
you know I can't fight the narrative
that's coming at me from all sides ride
of course Devon of course this is a page
straight out of trumps playbook I will
release my taxes once irrelevant and
possibly non-existent audits are
completed well but Donald Trump are you
under audit for every year there must be
some recent years you're not currently
being audited for right what about
releasing some of those I'm under audit
once it's done I'll release the taxes
never happened of course and then I'll
have some new reason because it's
political the seeking of my taxes is
political or whatever else I have new
details about Barack Obama's birth
certificate which I will share whenever
doesn't happen the entire thing was a
hoax
the birther Fiasco was a race-based
hit job done by some really ugly
elements of the American right with the
help of then reality show host Donald
Trump whatever this is not what an
innocent person sounds like and
eventually they are you know what the
transition will be we've seen it with
everything it'll go from it never
happened to okay Devon Nunez was in
Vienna and sure he met with Viktor
shokan but that's not a crime he wanted
corruption to be investigated in Ukraine
and of course that continues to be a
meme that they rest on but why aren't we
asking if Ukraine is as corrupt as Trump
and everybody says they are
why would you go to them and ask them to
investigate corruption doesn't really
make any sense why would you go to a
burglar and say I need you above anyone
else to investigate burglary you
wouldn't do it it doesn't make any sense
and from the beginning we knew that and
it's only becoming increasingly
transparent now so we'll see when they
shift to shift from I didn't do it to I
did it but there's nothing wrong with
that that's just called politics one of
the day's sponsors is privacy dot-com /
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy calm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen
it doesn't matter because I've already
deleted that virtual card and that's the
beauty of privacy calm there are a ton
of advantages to using a free service
like this for example you can sign up
for as many free trials as you want then
just delete the virtual credit card you
used and never worry about getting
charged for it it protects you from
getting hacked it protects you when
companies are hacked which happens all
the time it is all completely free all
you have to do is click the link under
this video to get started and for a
limited time they're giving everyone in
our audience $5 towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link